[Music]
foreign
welcome back
so we've been talking a lot about
differential equations and derivatives
of functions and today I'm going to talk
about numerical differentiation how you
differentiate functions without taking
the limit
as you know Delta X or delta T goes to
zero so we're going to be looking at
some function in this lecture F of T
okay so we have some time variable some
f of T and you'll recall from kind of
your high school or college Calculus
class or from the review earlier that
you can essentially approximate this
derivative at some point t
by the slope of the line connecting F at
T and F at t plus some little delta T so
some little delta T here and this line
connecting these two points is going to
approximate the slope of the tangent
line at T which is the derivative DF DT
so given a function given
a function
and we're going to say given a function
f of T and everything I'm going to tell
you today doesn't actually only apply to
functions F of T this would also apply
if you wanted to take the numerical
derivative of a data set let's say I
have measurements of some system in time
and I want to approximate the derivative
from that measurement data that also
works so given a function
or data
and this is a big deal right like data
science is becoming a huge part of all
of science if you want to get a job in
Industry oftentimes you're going to be
doing numerical differentiation not on
functions but on actual raw measurement
data so what I'm going to show you is
general for a function or for data so
given a function f of T we know that we
Define the derivative DF DT
dfdt is the limit
as delta T goes to zero as delta T goes
to zero of my F at this point on the
right that's F of t plus delta T minus
my my value F at the point on the left F
of f of T divided by delta T and so
essentially what we're doing is we're
taking the limit as this approach
becomes infinitesimally close to the
point on the left so we're making delta
T go to zero so these points get
arbitrarily close together and this
dashed line is going to get closer and
closer and closer and closer to that
perfect tangent line which is the
derivative at F of T okay that's uh you
know that's what we know from calculus
and we've spent a lot of time in our
lives
taking this limit as delta T goes to
zero and really making this
infinitesimal limit to get this
derivative so that's how we are used to
thinking about the derivative DF DT but
what I'm going to show you in this
lecture and probably the next five or
ten lectures is that numerically when
you want to do this on a computer or
when you want to do this on data it's
often convenient not to take the limit
as delta T goes to zero and just to say
that this is
approximately equal to this expression
here so we can approximate the
derivative of a function DF DT by taking
this simple finite difference this
difference over a finite delta T time
step
and so this is going to be the basis of
most of numerical differentiation
numerical integration of functions if I
want to simulate an ordinary
differential equation if I want to
simulate something like
um
DX DT equals f of x then I can
approximate DX DT using this formula I
can say that you know DX DT is
approximately
X at t plus delta T minus X at T divided
by delta T this is approximately equal
to f of x
and this is f of x at time T let's just
be very very explicit here f of x at
time t
f x at time t
so all I've done here this is my
differential equation I'm interested in
simulating all I'm doing is
approximating this derivative using this
finite difference here and so pretty
easy to just multiply delta T on both
sides and add X of T and I get an
expression for X at time t plus delta T
which is approximately equal to exit t
plus Delta t f
of X at T
and so this is actually a an update rule
you can code this up in a computer in
Python and Matlab and Julia whatever you
prefer you can code this up and if you
have the state of your system X at time
T and you can evaluate the right hand
side F
at X of T then everything on the right
is known and I can approximate X at the
next time step
and then if I have this data I can plug
that in for x and f of x and I can
approximate X at the next time step and
I can step my system forward in time
this is called a numerical integrator so
we can integrate our ordinary
differential equations using this kind
of finite difference approximation to
the derivative Okay so
sure and this is not the only
information to the derivative this is
actually kind of a bad approximation to
the derivative this is going to as we're
going to show this has a pretty big
error and this is actually not the best
numerical integrator this is kind of a
poor numerical integrator so what we're
going to do in this lecture and in the
next few lectures is we're going to look
at things like what is the error in this
approximation we know it's only
approximately equal to this so what is
that error is it big is it small does it
scale with delta T does it get smaller
when delta T gets smaller if so how fast
you know if delta T gets 10 10 smaller
does this get 10 times smaller we're
going to ask and answer questions like
that so things like you know what are
the error of these schemes what are some
better schemes you know better formulas
that would give me a higher accuracy
approximation of this derivative and
then in a few lectures we're going to
start using it for this numerical
integration scheme here that I'm
alluding to okay
and we're going to be able to do this
all on functions F of t or if I have
data sets if I have you know literally
data collected at discrete Delta T's
um you know maybe my boss emails me a
data set and says hey what's the
derivative of this data what's the rate
of change of this data in time I'll show
you how to
um you know approximate those
derivatives numerically on data as well
so that's all coming up
um and so let's jump in I think I want
to actually do this today
so the basic way that we are going to
understand the error of these kinds of
approximations so we're going to start
by just looking at this one and then I'm
going to drive a few better better ones
uh the way that we're going to
approximate this error is by looking at
the Taylor series expansion of this F of
t plus delta T about a base Point F of T
so we're going to expand this thing out
we're going to get a bunch of terms uh
and then we're going to see kind of how
the
um the full expansion relates to this
derivative so I'm going to write down
some math I'm going to write down
um
equation one is going to be F of t plus
delta T
and you should be really good at
Computing these uh these Taylor series
expansions if you don't remember just go
to the video uh the refresher on Taylor
series
so this equals F of t
plus the derivative DF DT DF DT
evaluated at time T times delta T
plus Delta t squared over 2 factorial
times the second derivative DF squared
DT squared evaluated at t plus delta T
cubed over 3 factorial times the third
derivative of f with respect to T cubed
at t plus dot dot dot dot and I'm just
going to say order
delta T to the fourth and higher okay so
I want you to get used to this notation
this kind of Big O notation this order
this kind of a curly o of delta T to the
fourth that means that this is an
infinite series
uh and all of the terms have at least a
power of delta T to the fourth or higher
it's ordered delta T to the fourth or
higher that's what that little o means
right there
so this is the Taylor series of f of t
plus delta T and I'm also going to write
down the Taylor series of f of T minus
delta T this point here because we're
also going to compare you know what is
what if I approximate my derivative
using this slope on the left
or what if I approximate my derivative
using the slope between these two points
t plus delta T and T minus delta T which
one of those is better which one is more
accurate which one will have more error
we're going to understand them using
these Taylor series so just bear with me
I'm going to write down the Taylor
series for f of T minus delta T it's
going to be very similar
star star equation
F of T minus delta T
equals and I'm pretty sure the only
thing that's going to be different is
that these Delta T's are going to be
negative Delta T's and so the odd terms
are going to be negative while the even
terms are still going to be positive
so this is still F of T now we get minus
Delta t d f d t evaluated at T
plus Delta t squared over 2 factorial D
Squared f
d t squared evaluated T now minus whoops
that's not supposed to happen
uh minus delta T cubed over 3 factorial
D cubed f
DT cubed evaluated t plus dot dot dot
because all I'm doing here is I'm
plugging in a negative delta T every
time I see a delta T here and so all the
odd Powers Negative to an odd power is
still negative are negative all the even
powers are positive because negative
squared and to the fourth are positive
so these are going to be the two Taylor
series approximations we're going to use
to understand the error of these types
of expressions
um and so what we're going to do is
we're going to compute you know I'm
literally going to plug this in here and
I'm going to cancel some terms out and
see it's going to look a lot like dfdt
but there's going to be some error
associated with this approximation and
we're going to quantify and analyze and
understand that and then we're going to
see can we cook up a better scheme than
this using these Taylor series
okay so let's do that
um and so I'm just going to start off
with the simplest one and then we're
going to build to more and more
sophisticated so we're going to start
off with this uh this is called the
forward difference because I take the
difference of my point I care about t
and a point to the forward of it a
forward difference with t plus delta T
so
um
let me actually just write that down so
forward
difference this is one scheme
mathematicians are always scheming okay
so forward different scheme is uh
dfdt is approximately equal to F of t
plus delta T
minus F of T divided by delta T and so
now what I'm going to do is I'm
literally just going to take this star
equation plug it in here cancel as much
stuff as I can and we're going to see
how close does that equal actual DF DT
which is what I want
and so
um
I'm gonna do some of this in my head if
this is really not hard you can pause
here and actually write this out long
form if you want but it's pretty easy
what we're doing is we're taking
um f of t plus delta T minus F of t
so if I subtract F of T I get rid of
this first term and I just have
everything to the right of that
and then I'm going to divide by delta T
so I've subtracted this F of T now I'm
dividing by delta T so all of these
powers of delta T get dropped by one
power
so I have DF DT
plus D Squared F DT times a single delta
T over 2 factorial this term is going to
be this term but with a Delta t squared
because I divided by delta T and so on
and so forth so this equals you know we
we got rid of this divided by delta T
so this equals DF DT
Plus
D Squared f
DT squared
times delta T over 2 factorial plus and
I could write this out you know I have a
D Squared you know sorry D cubed f d t
cubed Delta t squared over 3 factorial
plus dot dot dot higher order terms so
this is like this expansion here if I
take the exact Taylor series for this
term and I plug it in and I cancel all
the terms I get
the thing I want
and all of this is error
okay all of this is the error in this
approximation so this finite difference
forward difference derivative is what I
want plus some error and the error is we
say this is on the order of delta T
because what we're going to be doing is
making delta T smaller to control this
error and if we make delta T smaller
this term is going to be the one that
dominates so if I for a small delta T
Delta t squared is so much smaller than
delta T to the first Power that we
basically say that all of these are
negligible and this is the leading order
error term so this is the leading
leading
order
error term
okay and so this error is on the order
of Delta X basically every error term
has a Delta X or higher power
and so I'm going to come back and we're
going to talk about what this error
means but but just right now very
briefly what this means is that I can
control the error of my approximation I
can make the error of this approximation
smaller by making Delta that's not Delta
X that should be delta T I can make the
error in my approximation smaller by
making delta T smaller okay by making
Delta
by making delta T smaller
so in this case because my leading error
is just linearly proportional to delta T
if I want my error to be 10 times less I
should make my delta T 10 times smaller
if I want my error to be a hundred times
less I should make my delta T a hundred
times smaller and again these terms here
are so negligible I'm just going to
ignore them if I make my delta T 100
times smaller this term gets 100 times
smaller this term gets 10 000 times
smaller
the next term gets a million times
smaller so they get smaller so much
faster I only really have to care about
this leading error term here and so this
is the name of the game you can take an
approximation you can use the Taylor
series to figure out is it the thing I
want in the first place and what is the
error of that approximation
good so I'm going to write down a few
others and then we're going to you know
plot them in Matlab and actually see if
the error behaves the way we we expect
it to okay so that was forward
difference
um maybe I'll switch to to Orange now
and I'll do a backward difference
backward uh difference
and this backward difference is exactly
the same except now we're going to use f
of T and F of T minus delta T so we're
going to say DF DT is approximately
equal to F of T minus
F of T minus delta T
divided by delta T
and again I'm going to take this star
star equation here for this Taylor
series and plug it in here and now it is
f of T minus all of this so these F of
T's still cancel
and all of these terms become negative
of what they are and then I divide by
delta T so I killed the F of t i divided
by delta T and I have a minus sign so
again the first term is DF DT which is
good
there's no delta T because I divided by
delta T
the second term is minus
D Squared f d t squared
delta T over 2 factorial now plus d
cubed f d t cubed Delta t squared over 3
factorial plus dot dot again and so
again
this is the thing I want and this is all
of my error my error is here and again
this error you can see it has the exact
same form it's on the order of delta T
you know it's just there's a minus sign
here and a plus sign here that doesn't
matter but it's on the order
of delta T which means again backwards
difference in forwards difference are
going to have approximately the same
error scaling with delta T okay so if I
want to make my error smaller here I
have to make my delta T smaller
proportionally
good
um and so you might ask yourself well
are all finite difference derivatives
using you know these these points at a
delta T apart are all of them order
delta T can we do better than this
and so you might already be thinking
well how do I use this information to
get a better approximation of my
derivative and so what you might do is
you might think well
if I can all of my error here is coming
from this third term in my Taylor series
so so far all of my error uh has ended
up being from this term here these kind
of uh Delta t squared times the second
derivative of f we call that the
curvature of f how much it curves
because we're dividing by delta T here
so what if I could develop a scheme that
cancels those two terms out and pushes
my error to this next delta T cubed term
that would probably be a better scheme
and so that is actually a really good
idea and that is called a central
difference that's what I drew here in
this really faint blue line that you can
barely see
is that if I drew a line between t plus
delta T and T minus delta T if I use
that
as my approximation of my slope that
might do a better job because I claim
it's going to cancel out these these
Taylor series terms so this is called
Central difference
Central difference
and so the central difference derivative
is going to be
essentially we're going to take I'm just
going to subtract these two first and
then I'm going to divide by delta T okay
so I'm actually going to constructively
build the center difference we're
literally going to take you know the
first equation minus the second equation
which is uh F of t plus delta T minus F
of T minus delta T let's hope I don't
mess this up
and this is where it gets kind of cool
because these have neg like this is the
term I want this DF DT
because these have negative signs if I
subtract this one from this one I just
get twice as much DF DT so that's kind
of cool so all the odd terms cancel I'm
sorry all the even terms cancel my f of
T's cancel when I subtract this from
this my Delta t squared terms cancel my
delta T to the fourth terms cancel
because those are all even and have the
same sign
and all my odd terms just get multiplied
by two because this minus negative
itself is just two times itself
so this equals
all these terms cancel and I just get
these odd terms so this is 2
DF DT Delta X delta T sorry these are
not Delta X's we're taking finite Delta
T's
this would all work if you wanted to
take the derivative of a function of
space of X you just replace all the t's
with x's no big deal
so two DF DT times delta T
my even terms here cancel so now I get
my odd terms so this would be plus
um
two delta T
cubed over 3 factorial D cubed f d t
cubed
plus dot dot dot and now if I want to be
really clever I'll notice that my fourth
order term is probably also going to get
canceled because it's even so you know
star minus double star all the even
terms die so this is not order delta T
cubed this is actually going to be order
delta T to the fifth because the next
term I'm going to have in my series is a
is the odd delta T to the fifth term and
then the sixth order is going to die and
I'll get a seventh order and then the
eighth order is not going to be there
but I'll get a ninth order I only have
the odd terms in this
and so you see this is actually already
doing a much better job
of isolating the thing I want this dfdt
and now my error is higher order I have
killed my Delta t squared and I only
have my delta T cubed so now I can take
this scheme and I should probably divide
by 2 delta T to get to isolate the thing
I want
so
DF DT
is approximately equal to F of t plus
delta T
minus F of T minus delta T
divided by 2 delta T
that's going to equal the thing I want
DF DT
plus an error term
which is Delta t squared
over 3 factorial D cubed F DT cubed
plus order delta T to the fifth okay
plus dot dot dot plus all of that stuff
and so again this is the thing we wanted
so this is actually a good approximation
of the thing we wanted the first
derivative DF DT and now my leading
order error term all of this is error
and so my error is on the order now of
Delta t squared
and this is a really big deal okay so my
error being on the order of Delta t
squared is a really really big deal what
that means
is that if I want my my approximation to
be a hundred times better
I only have to make delta T 10 times
smaller so if I make delta T 10 times
smaller my error gets 100 times smaller
whereas up here if I wanted 100 times
less error I need it 100 times smaller
delta T and this is a big deal this
means that if I want a good accurate
approximation of my derivative on data
with this scheme I need to collect 10
times less data than with these schemes
to have the same error accuracy okay I
need I need a delta T that's 10 times
smaller here than here to get 100 times
more accurate data and that gets even
worse the more accurate I want this is
literally like Delta t squared so if I
wanted it a million times more accurate
I would divide delta T by a thousand
here but I'd still have to divide delta
T by a million here that's much much
worse
okay good um that is mostly what I
wanted to show you
maybe what I'll do for the last step is
I will erase this and we'll actually
code these up and
um and I'll show you kind of what uh
what that looks like in Python and
Matlab so stay tuned
or stay put rather
okay so now we have
kind of either written down or derived
these different approximations of the
first derivative DF DT of my function
and using the Taylor series what we have
found is that we get the the derivative
we want plus a finite amount of error
which scales with the little time step
the little delta T I'm using to
approximate this derivative okay
um
and so now what we're going to do is
we're just going to code up these three
schemes the forward difference backward
different Central difference and maybe
I'll draw a tiny little cartoon down
here just to remind ourselves you know
this is pretty simple but I'll just do
my little tiny cartoon here and I have
you know so this is the point I care
about t
and then this is t plus delta T this is
T minus delta T
and this is you know F of t f of t plus
Delta t f of T minus delta T so the
forward difference approximation is
this red line here the backward
difference approximation is the slope of
this orange line here and the central
difference approximation is the slope of
this blue line
here which you can almost see I think
you can convince yourself that that blue
line is already doing a better job than
either the orange line or the pink line
the orange line is overshooting the pink
lines undershooting and actually you can
see that the the pink line
is uh kind of it's off because this
thing has a positive uh what is the
curvature the second derivative of this
is negative actually and so it this is a
negative error term because this
curvature is negative and so this is
undershooting the pink line is is too
small
the orange line I erased it but I had an
error term that was minus D Squared F DT
that was the the negative of the
curvature that would be a positive
number so the orange line is actually
overshooting this it's too high and the
blue line is doing much better because
its error is now proportional to the
third derivative at times something much
much smaller Delta t squared okay so
we're gonna do this uh in Matlab we'll
do this in Python basically the same
thing um you don't have to worry about
which which one you want so what we're
going to do
um
is
we're going to start by picking some
delta T that is not too small but not
too big delta T equals 0.2 and I'm going
to define a Time Vector from minus 2 to
4 in increments uh this really should be
in increments of DT
oh no I'm sorry I'm what I'm doing here
is I'm picking a really really small DT
just for plotting and then we're going
to plot our derivative on top of that so
I'm picking a really you know a small DT
for plotting and I'm defining F of t
equals sine of T that's just some
function I know the derivative of I know
the derivative of f of T exactly is
cosine of T so I'm going to plot my
approximate derivatives these guys here
I'm going to plot that against my exact
cosine of T derivative on this this fine
delta T just for plotting in the next
lecture I'm going to do this on data so
here we're going to assume we actually
have access to this function f so for
example when we compute DF DT uh you
know we're going to take sine of t plus
delta T you know sine of t plus delta T
minus sine of T divided by delta T this
assumes I have access to that function f
of T which in my case is sine in the
next lecture I'll show you how do you do
this if I just have a vector of data if
I just have a vector of data but I can't
ask for that function at any point I
just have a vector of data how do we
approximate these that's that's the next
lecture but for now I'm assuming we have
access to DF DT
okay so first things first I'm going to
plot my clean function f my fine exact
function and I'm going to plot the exact
derivative
um and let's just see what that looks
like
okay easy so I should probably label my
axes this is time maybe I'll I'll do
that
so this is X label
I don't know how to spell X label is
time
y label is f
of t or DF DT so
let's say my function
okay so time and whatever function
whether it's the function or the
derivative and these are the two
functions so that's really good now what
I'm going to do is I'm going to start
Computing this forward difference
approximation for each of these points
and we're going to plot those okay
so the forward difference is going to be
um
I'm literally going to take in Matlab
this is kind of easy because T is a
vector of time if I evaluate sine of
that Vector T it's going to give me a
vector of outputs sine at each of those
values so I can take that Vector t plus
my delta T and it'll give me the output
you know of that entire Vector of times
plus a delta T So f plus delta T at all
of the times I cared about
minus sine of T divided by DT so that's
my forward difference so this big f
means forward the big b means backwards
this is just sine of T minus sine of T
minus delta T divided by DT and then the
central difference Big C here is sine of
t plus delta T minus sine of T minus
delta T divided by 2 delta T and I'm
just going to plot all three of those
and we're going to see which ones are
better or worse okay
let's hope this works
I should probably have run everything
okay good
and so now this is a little bit
cluttered but you can see right the
function is this dashed line and then
all of my derivatives are these
different uh these kind of different
colored lines here so you can see that I
have my exact derivative in white my
forward difference in yellow backwards
difference in pink and Central
difference in cyan
and so if I wanted to I could probably
zoom in
uh on a region here so I could zoom in
on a region here
and you would see for example just like
we predicted the forward difference
derivative is over predicting so this
this kind of blue white line here that's
the exact derivative and my central
difference so they're almost perfect my
exact derivative which is just cosine of
T and my central difference are almost
perfectly on top of each other so that's
awesome and my forward difference is
overshooting uh the yellow curve my
forward difference is overshooting in
this case because I guess this has a
positive curvature my backwards
difference pink is undershooting it's
predicting a little bit too small of a
derivative and my central difference is
doing almost perfect it's it's really
really good I'm pretty sure if I zoomed
in a little more I would see
um you know I'm pretty sure I could see
some error if I zoomed in enough
but look at how much I have to zoom in
to see any error at all it's almost
perfect
actually compute these things if I have
a function f i can query at a point you
know t plus delta T T minus delta T and
T and it also shows that the central
difference is way way better than all of
these other schemes
um what I should probably do now is also
pick a bigger delta T let's say 0.5 this
is probably going to be terrible
0.5 is not really a small delta T right
we're making kind of an infinitesimal
approximation here and delta T .5 is not
that infinitesimal so as you can see all
of the errors got bigger by eye so if I
zoom in a little bit
let's just zoom in a little bit
yeah you can already see that they're
bigger
so there's more error in fact the
central difference is also you know even
by eye you can see the central
difference is diff is is bigger and the
central difference is getting bigger at
certain places and smaller at other
places that has to do with this this
cubic sorry this third order derivative
DF D cubed f d t cubed so the leading
effect of this error term is this Delta
t squared that means if I make delta T
smaller or bigger this is how the error
will scale but it is multiplied by this
kind of constant or this function really
and so when D when when the third
derivative of f is really large this
error will be larger when the third
derivative is really small this will be
really small and what's the third
derivative of sine first derivatives
cosine second derivative is sine third
derivative is cosine so I predict that
the error of my central difference will
be large whenever you know cosine of f
cosine of T is large that's that's
because of this this term here
good
um that was pretty easy Let's uh let's
switch to python
okay so we're going to you know plot
these we're going to compute and plot
these finite difference uh forward
difference backward different Central
difference in Python now and what we're
going to do is we're going to apply this
to an F of T that we know what its
derivative is so we're going to use f of
T equals sine of T we know its exact
derivative is cosine of T and so we're
going to plot these approximations
against that exact derivative so we're
going to compute this on a you know T
equals negative 2 to 4 with a fine
resolution we're going to plot the the
function and its derivative
so that's like literally what we have
here this is the function and its
derivative as a function of time and
then we're going to approximate for this
delta T equals 0.2 DT equals 0.2
we're going to approximate the forward
difference that's big F the backwards
difference that's Big B and the central
difference that's Big C
as sine of my t Vector plus delta T
minus sine of my t Vector divided by
delta T that's my four difference
backwards difference is sine of my t
Vector that's F of T minus sine of T
minus delta T divided by delta T and
this is going to evaluate this at that
whole Vector of points t t is a vector
of points all of those points minus
delta T
and then my central difference is sine
of t plus delta T minus sine of T minus
delta T divided by 2 delta T and when we
plot all of those next to each other we
find in fact
it's a little dark it's a little hard to
see but you can see kind of uh there is
this you know the true derivative this
cosine is the true derivative and then
all three of my curves are actually
pretty close they're all you know
shadowing this this true derivative
pretty accurately and if we zoom in you
can see that the uh the forward
difference at least on on the right hand
side of this on on this side of the
Curve
the forward difference is under
predicting the backwards difference is
over predicting and the central
difference which is this blue curve is
almost perfectly on top of this white
curve so Central difference is totally
nailing this derivative and there's a
little bit of error in these again based
on the curvature if we did
on the left side here instead of on the
right
the forward and backwards difference
errors would flip in that case then
forward difference would be
overpredicting and backwards would be
underpredicting because in this point
we'd have a you know a certain positive
curvature as opposed to a negative
curvature down here okay and those are
subtle things that you can read off of
this this Taylor series expansion here
the other thing you can do I would
encourage you to do this is to change
your delta T make it bigger make it 0.5
and you'll see the error get way bigger
maybe I'll just do this real quick so
I'm going to run these
I'm going to make my DT 0.5
okay I do all of this stuff
uh compute my finite derivatives and now
when I make DT 0.5 you see that my error
noticeably gets bigger Central
difference is still doing pretty good
it's still doing way way better than
those in fact it's doing even more
better because they're doing much worse
and this gets better faster with delta T
and then I can also do delta T equals
0.1
uh let's do that
okay and when delta T is small enough
even the forward and backwards different
schemes are almost perfect their error
shrinks proportional to delta T
Okay so
we're going to do things like compute
what is the Taylor series expansion for
D Squared f d t how do we approximate D
Squared FDT the second derivative again
we'll use Taylor series to cancel out
stuff except for the term we want which
is the second derivative and we'll talk
about how to compute this on data so
that'll all be in the next lecture thank
you
[Music]
foreign